monsieur le président cher françois
bayrou mesdames et messieurs les
parlementaires chers amis je suis très
heureux et très honoré de pouvoir
participer au congrès du modem même si
c'est par visioconférence interposés je
voudrais d'abord vous dire qu'au
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la relance un immense merci merci à
tous les parlementaires
merci au président du groupe patrick
mignola merci aux parlementaires avec
qui je travaille le plus étroitement je
pense en particulier à jean noël barrot
sur les sujets budgétaire parce que
depuis 2010 est vous avez apporté au
ministère de l'économie et des finances
sur tous les textes législatifs que ce
soit la loi pacte ou les différents
budgets que nous avons étudié un soutien
franc massif constructif utile pour la
majorité est utile pour la france
la qualité de vos travaux la qualité de
vos réflexions la qualité de vos
critiques de vos propositions nous ont
aidés à améliorer les textes que nous
proposions aux français et donc à rester
fidèle à l'esprit du président de la
république dépasser les clivages
politiques au service de l'ensemble des
français est au service de la nation
française je veux remercier aussi les
ministres membres du gouvernement avec
lesquels je travaille étroitement le
ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement marc fesneau qu une
responsabilité très lourde
la ministre geneviève darrieussecq la
ministre chargée des territoires
jacqueline gourault avec qui par
définition parce que notre économie doit
être territoriales nous travaillons
étroitement et en toute confiance
devrait également vous dire à quel point
je suis convaincu que nous avons fait du
bon travail mais le plus dur est devant
nous nous sommes dans une période agitée
nous sommes confrontés à la crise
économique la plus grave depuis 1929
nous allons avoir besoin de faire preuve
d'unité de dépassement de soi et
d'imagination pour apporter des
solutions les plus efficaces pour le
pays
ma conviction profonde c'est que les
choix que nous avons fait avec le
président de la république emmanuel
macron avec le premier ministre
castex avec l'ensemble des
parlementaires
les choix les plus justes et les plus
efficaces pour le pays
protéger notre économie protéger les
restaurateurs les bars les salles de
sport le monde de la culture
tous les secteurs qui sont les plus
touchés par la crise c'est un choix
juste et c'est un choix efficace parce
qu'ils protègent nos compétences et nos
savoir faire engager dès maintenant la
relance économique pour avoir au bout du
compte à la sortie de la crise une
économie qui soit plus compétitive plus
décarbonée c'est aussi le choix juste et
de choix efficace pour notre pays et
vous y avez participé pleinement en
travaillant sur les travaux de la
relance et sur ce plan de relance qui
j'en suis convaincue sera efficace pour
notre pays et nous permettra d'ici 2022
de retrouver le même niveau de
développement économique que celui que
nous avions en 2019
je veux dire enfin un mot plus
personnelle pour votre président
françois bayrou il a désormais au delà
de ses responsabilités politiques
une responsabilité très lourde qui est
de dégager la vision de long terme pour
notre pays nous avons toujours travaillé
main dans la main avec françois bayrou
en bonne intelligence et je sais que ce
sera le cas dans les mois à venir
nous avons besoin de la décision que
nous prenons pour la protection de notre
économie pour la relance de l'activité
économique de réflexion de plus long
terme encore pour savoir quelle france
nous voulons laisser à nos enfants
quelle france nous voulons bâtir quelle
place nous voulons lui donner dans la
construction européenne et sur la scène
internationale je suis convaincu que la
tête du plan il fera un travail
remarquablement utile pour notre pays et
pour notre majorité
vous voyez le modem est pour moi un
partenaire précieux les qualités du
travaux que nous avons fait ensemble
vous dois beaucoup
donc je tiens à vous remercier très
chaleureusement et vous souhaiter
évidemment un excellent congrès à votre
président françois bayrou et à chacun
d'entre vous merci à tous